make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
so i was sitting here thinking what my
second video today was gonna be
and and the more i thought about it the
more i was like you know we haven't
really had a discussion for a little
while on on stories
and i thought it'd be kind of
interesting to have this conversation
talking about deceased versus marvel
zombies
right because i feel like this is a huge
talking point across comic book fandom
right i've been seeing all kinds of
reddit posts about it and different
things like that and
it's an interesting concept it's a good
question right because you know marvel
zombies resurrection
has just recently come back in mobile
comics right they did issue number zero
basically kind of like the the
prelude or the prologue or whatever you
want to call it setting everything up
and kind of establishing hey this is the
general idea
and then a year later we get issue
number one i don't know why they chose
to wait a year my only guess
and and i still kind of stand by this i
feel like marvel learned that dc was
gonna do a zombie story and they wanted
to kind of quote unquote beat them to
the punch but they didn't really have a
plan for it they didn't really know what
it was going to look like they just kind
of wanted to get issue number zero out
there and say hey guys we got zombies
coming back and i think the biggest
problem with that is in the time they
waited
dc launched deceased and it's proved to
be a highly successful story
but in terms of of the concepts between
these two you know looking at these
these stories you can kind of go with
marvel zombies resurrection
the issue with that is is twofold first
i think it's a very lackluster story in
comparison to the original zombies of
course they had two distinctly different
tones and two
because of the fact that marvel zombies
resurrection isn't really fleshed out
there's not a whole lot that we can do
there right i mean we can kind of look
at what we have so far and say okay so
basically like there's a plague that led
to people becoming infected with a
zombie virus and now they're on earth
but looking at these differences and
this even extends to dc
looking at these differences the
original marvel zombies by robert
kirkman was
kind of like a dark comedy you couldn't
really go into it expecting something
serious
i mean i guess you could have when you
heard marvel zombies but by the time you
get maybe even a few pages into issue
number one
it starts off pretty dark with most
everything being eaten and then the
characters get a little silly and i
agree with most people
in saying that marvel zombies went off
the rails like really fast and
nonetheless you know it was kind of a
dark comedy story you know by the time
he finished marvel zombies won marvel
zombies two
it was pretty dark by the time he got
into like army of darkness dead days
things like that it was like okay you
know this is uh getting a little campy
and i guess marvel was really wanting to
play into that but deceased is a wholly
different tone
right you know deceased is not a story
where it's told from the perspective of
the dead it's not really campy and it's
not really a dark comedy it's just a
dark story and it's kind of interesting
because the only time we ever really saw
a story involving zombies from dc
comics came with uh blackest night and
blackest night was just designed to be a
kind of soft reboot right i mean that's
one of the things that we've talked
about before that the blackest night
event
was dc kind of looking at the landscape
of heroes that had been killed off
over the course of you know all the
events that took place after crisis
undefeated earth and then asking the
question how do we bring them back
right and so you basically you know all
the dead heroes are resurrected in
blackest night and then in brightest day
dc only chooses to keep a few they
are purified of the black lantern
deafness whatever it is
you know using a white lantern ring and
ultimately they stay alive it served
that purpose but in terms of it being
like a tried and true zombie story
wasn't really the case
right it wasn't anything like deceased
uh if i'm being honest with you guys i
kind of think the thing that really
elevates deceased
is hope it world's end by tom taylor it
feels a lot like injustice except a
zombie story and i don't mean to say
that because i think the tom taylor kind
of typecasts and as far as his writing
goes it's just
the kind of you know it's nice to see it
sort of fill in the gaps right you know
for us to kind of get this main story
and then you know hope it works in
effectively being a tie-in series you
know that just kind of gives us
all the little mortar between the bricks
and and so on and so forth but i think
in comparison to the original marvel
zombies i think that deceased
is a lot more in depth but it's also
less grand in scale at least so far
right because with marvel zombies you
saw like galactus showing up and then
they ate galactus and they took off and
they ate the universe and all that kind
of stuff so it was a lot more
a lot more expanded in that way there
were a lot of things that we didn't see
which is kind of where that expansion
falls short you don't really see the
marvel zombies fighting against like the
cree
or the scrolls or anything along those
lines you don't really see how they fare
against like the cosmic entities and so
on and so forth instead
you know it was just kind of you know
like we you know the incredible hulk ate
everything out there in existence and
now here we are
and that's basically it um but there is
a lot more world world building
that goes on in deceased and i think
because of that you know if you kind of
have to compare pound for pound i would
definitely
say deceased really seems to come out on
top but the cool thing is
because we're only one issue in to
marvel zombies resurrection it could
prove to be wildly successful
just from what i've seen again you know
it's it doesn't really quite grab me the
way the dc's did and in all honesty i
think it's only really fair for us as
comic book fans to sit down and read
that story and to not really be able to
help but compare it to deceased right
because it's marvel's more recent zombie
story and
and really kind of seems to be an answer
to what dc is doing you know i think
that having characters like franklin
richards you know
creates a lot of interest and intrigue
especially when we when we start
throwing in characters like blue marvel
right adam brusher or we see that
spider-man is being
depicted in a different way right he's
not a zombie this time right and we
don't really know
what all went down i think the time will
tell right i mean it's only a four issue
limited series the real question to ask
here is whether or not marvel is going
to do what dc
what dc comics did because i think that
when the original dc's comic came out
and the comic book finished we had more
questions that were left unanswered than
we had questions that were answered is
superman gonna come back what's gonna
happen to the heroes did they just bail
on earth and that's it like was there
anybody left behind because there were a
lot of familiar faces that we did not
see
in deceased right red hood was one of
the most notable examples right when we
were covering that story when the comic
came out and you saw all of your social
media
everybody was asking what happened to
jason todd right like where's the red
hood in all of this were characters like
deathstroke and where characters like
like razor ghoul and
all that kind of stuff you know we're
getting answers to those questions now
but i think that adding a companion
series to fill in and answer all those
questions was a huge
benefit for the dc stories whether or
not marvel will do that i don't know and
and what i'm
kind of afraid of here is is marvel's
got enough popular titles going already
but they've got you know
what is it avengers by jason aaron you
know he just finished his store run
which is probably one of the greatest
thor runs of all time you've got venom
by donnie cates you've got guardians of
the galaxy that's being written you have
tadahasi coates captain america which is
probably one of the best stories that
nobody's reading uh you have a lot of
these really cool comics coming out and
i'm afraid that the zombies line is kind
of considered to be an off
an afterthought and i think for dc that
was even the case as well dc's was just
kind of like a story that we're doing
you know and that was it and then
because it proved to be so popular i
think dc was like oh wait a minute guys
i think we got a winner on our hands
here okay tom taylor uh fill in the gaps
and that was that was basically what it
turned into but i'm kind of afraid
that with marvel zombies resurrection
that marvel is so eager to create
something
that can offer competition to dc comics
that they're gonna rush it right they're
just gonna kind of rush it out it's
gonna be
sort of slammed together and just thrown
out there and if we do end up getting a
kind of companion series then it's just
going to be sort of haphazardly thrown
together not a whole lot of thought is
going to go into it but again we're only
one issue in right so
it's not really fair to compare the
singular issue that came out
with marvel zombies resurrection to what
happened with deceased right because if
you look at the dc's comic even issue
number one if batman hadn't died in the
first issue it would have just been like
okay but like that was the big thing
that happened and it was like man things
are really dark right outside of that it
would not have been a very adventurous
lineup
a very adventurous first issue and so
again you know i think it's important to
kind of go you know
kind of give marvel zombies resurrection
time to see how it compares but as far
as deceased versus the original marvel
zombies my vote goes to deceased i think
it's
it's it's more tried and true of what i
would expect from a zombie
story from comics right like a darker
story like a darker take on the zombie
mythos a lot of the major characters we
would expect to to lift the experience
have all died right so it's very earth
two in that way right you know batman
suit man wonder woman all died in the
first issue of earth two right and then
you just got
all the other characters that came after
that but again you know just kind of my
thoughts here and i'm curious you know
how do you guys feel you know leave some
comments down below i'm i'm curious what
you're all's take is on marvel zombies
versus deceased so
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
you